100 billion barrels the largest oil
deposit uncovered in a generation Brazil
discovered some amazing reserves of oil
in the pre-salt
in 2006 Brazil stumbled upon the western
hemispheres biggest oil sign in three
decades 150 miles off the coast here in
Rio the discovery started an energy
frenzy and renewed hope for the future
but like so many booms and busts in
Brazil's past the potential may be
bigger than the payoff we are far from
the coast and they're deep in the water
so it requires a lot of technology to
extract the soil from where it is
Reynaldo Garcia is the CEO of GE Latin
America one of the firm's helping Brazil
Petrobras extract oil from below a mile
thick layer of salt a technological
challenge but one that could yield
enough oil to supply Brazil for a
century you imagine that this oil the
pre-salt it is several thousand feet
below the bottom of the sea so this oil
and gas plant in Rio de Janeiro ge is
producing risers giant pipes that can
carry oil from the pre-salt layer below
the ocean floor up four miles to ships
waiting above it's sound simple but it's
very complex and precise technology that
must withstand enormous pressure the
pressure for this project isn't just
coming from the bottom of the ocean it's
also coming from investors who expect
Brazil to pump five million barrels a
day from the Lula field one and a half
million of which would be exported
slowing the project down a government
mandate to get parts and labor locally
eg we see this localization requirement
as an opportunity because it creates an
industry it creates demand that demand
is fueling innovation inspiring
technology not just for Brazil but for
GE deep water operations around the
globe for exploration production in
Brazil can be also utilized in other
parts of the or the
North Sea the Gulf of Mexico but in
Brazil the petroleum promise has yet to
be fulfilled today it's just the words
11th biggest oil producer but it aims to
be in the top five by 2020
despite the technological and
bureaucratic hurdles GE is staying the
course we hope that the country will hit
the five million barrels per day by 2020
the signing out of the year is deciding
not to participate in a very large
market